in this course Tristan Wilcox will teach
you how to produce music with FL Studio
Tristan is a professional music producer
with over 10 000 hours experience in
music production FL Studio is a complete
software music production environment it
features a graphical user interface with
a pattern-based music sequencer when you
start music production you'll find that
one of the most difficult things to do
on your own is create your first
full-length track and that's why I
wanted the goal of this beginner course
to be that you'll have something done
you'll have something finished that you
can be proud of and that will apply all
the knowledge that we're going to learn
in this course the way that this course
is going to work is SMB divided into 10
chapters each one of these chapters is
going to be focused on one specific area
of music production that you're going to
be using every single time you open up a
project file in the description you'll
find that there is a link to FL Studio
you can download the free version and
follow along I'm personally going to be
using the paid Producer Edition but it's
not necessary and you'll be able to
follow along just fine without further
Ado let's go to chapter one
[Music]
foreign
now that you've downloaded FL Studio the
first thing that we're going to want to
do is go up to file in the top left
corner click new from template and then
click empty and what this is going to do
is it's going to prompt us to ask us to
save changes for the file we're just
going to click no and then from here
um we have a completely blank file and
so now we're all going to be working
from the same spot and if something was
open or accidentally opened in your
project it'll all be cleared so we're
all working for the same spot I think
that's important so the first thing
we're going to do is just try to get a
virtual instrument into our song So to
get a virtual instrument what we're
going to do is click this box up here
called our Channel rack and the channel
rack is a uh basically just like a box
that's going to hold all of our
instruments for the song so what we're
going to do now is we're going to open
up a brand new instrument in our Channel
rack so by clicking this plus icon it's
going to show us a tons of different
options for different instruments that
we can choose from and I'm going to
click on flex and I suggest I use flex
just to follow along and then after you
can mess around with different plugins
as we move throughout the course so by
clicking on Flex down here it's going to
load up our first virtual instrument
now once it loads you're going to see
that the channel rack is sort of
blocking our plugin so why don't we just
click X on the channel rack and then use
this top bar to kind of move this plugin
into view and right here we have our
virtual instrument so this isn't uh some
virtual instruments can be a singular
instrument so like there is a virtual
instrument called FL keys that is just a
piano and then there's some virtual
instruments like Flex and flex is going
to give you access to all kinds of
different virtual instruments it's more
of like a library of sorts that contains
more instruments inside of it and so
that's why I want to click on this one
because I wanted to show you guys all
the different sounds that you get right
out of the gate with FL Studio even in
the free version so I went ahead and I
downloaded all of the free
um packs that you can get and so if you
want to do that now you can download
those and you can see right here I I
these are the ones that they currently
have available and so um what I'm going
to do is I'm going to navigate to pianos
where it says essential pianos
and then it's going so you see it has
packs here and has presets here so think
of this like the category so you have
pianos guitars bass guitars and just
click through these you see and then on
presets it's going to give me different
kinds of pianos to choose from so I have
pianos and then the presets under pianos
I have close Grand and this is going to
sound a certain way
and by clicking this it opens up that
particular preset so to play this
virtual instrument what we're going to
do is we're going to click on any of the
keys Z through M I believe um you can
play key you can play different notes
using your own keyboard so
you can just play Keys like that which
is great I'm just using my keyboard down
here and if it's not working for you
make sure that you have this uh keyboard
piano enabled by making sure that that
icon right there is orange so now that
we have that turned on I'm going to go
through just different presets and I'm
just going to show you guys around and
just show you the different types of
instruments that you can play and use
for our songs so right here we have
essential guitars and I can click on
like Ace nylon light and so we have a
guitar here so
it's cool and then we can go in our
string section there's plenty of strings
to use as well you got the base base
we've got wind instruments you got
trumpets space actions brass I mean
so you've got plenty of really high
quality samples and things that we're
going to be using as we go along so the
next chapter we're going to be focusing
on how we can record Melodies and chords
and bass lines in using our virtual
instruments to start beginning our track
[Music]
all right now we're ready to start
making some patterns so what we're going
to do is we're going to navigate to the
piano section and just choose any preset
that you like here I'm personally going
to go with the close Grant and from here
we can just close out the flex plug-in
by clicking on the X icon here and we
will be staring at a empty projects
again now from here to start making our
pattern we're just going to click on the
Square left of the channel racket is
called the piano roll so once you click
that it's going to open up a new window
for us now this window is where you're
going to be placing all your chords
Melodies bass lines all kinds of things
like that
um and before we get started I'm just
going to show you the basic navigation
of the piano wall and we're going to
edit some settings to make it a little
easier to use so in the top left corner
you're going to find that there's this
little drop down menu
and if you click that um we can head
down to edit and just make sure you have
allow resizing from left enabled um it's
turned off by default and I'm not sure
why because it's extremely helpful to
use
um so you're going to want to enable
that
um the second thing that we have to
enable is go to view
scale highlighting and make sure that
this is set to automatic this is also
going to be really helpful for when
we're making cores and Melodies so
making sure that we're placing things on
key
um so from here uh the basic navigation
is fairly straightforward you have a
sliding bar at the top which lets you
move left and right and then you have a
sliding bar to your right which lets you
move up and down
um the way to kind of think about the
piano roll is that it's essentially a
piano that's flipped vertically so you
can see that if I uh scroll up and down
it's scrolling up and down the pitch of
the piano so we have these are going to
be higher notes the higher I go
[Music]
and then the lower I go it's going to be
lower notes
so that's essentially how it works and
then if I click play right here
um I'm going to switch it from song to
pattern since we're listening to our
pattern we're going to want it to sit to
this Orange right here and then if I hit
the space bar or click the play button
you'll see that it's going to start
going through
and so this right here
this little bar is going to play
whatever notes we have
um and it's going to play them in in a
sequence from left to right so if I just
put uh left click a green note in here
I'm just going to click once and it's in
a place and no and I'm going to do this
a couple times
to show you guys how it works so if I
click play again
[Music]
you can see that it plays it uh one
after the other so the pin roll is
pretty intuitive
um there's I don't feel like there needs
to be a ton of over explaining here but
before we start making Melodies I do
think that a couple more things are
going to be important to layout and that
is resizing the piano roll so this can
be really difficult I remember when I
first started my piano roll was zoomed
in extremely close like this and I had
to move notes like this and it was just
really really painful and nobody and I
couldn't find anything on how to make
this fixed so the way that you do it is
this if you scroll on this bar right
here uh the specifically the bar that
has the numbers on it if you use your
scroll wheel on this it's going to
resize it horizontally and then uh up in
this top right corner you have another
bar that lets you resize the piano roll
vertically and this is just really
helpful I know that like sometimes the
piano roll can be sized weird and it can
be really frustrating to try to make
Melodies if you're too close or too far
away from the notes so I'm just putting
that out there just in case one of you
was a little bit too zoomed in or so I
think now we're pretty much ready to go
over the basics of note manipulation so
I have these notes that I just left
clicked in here and there's a couple
things that we can do with them so the
first thing we can do is resize them so
if I hover to the end of a note you can
make it longer
or shorter
and then I can do that from the left
side and then if you remember this is
the setting that we just changed the
allow resizing from left allows you to
resize the notes from the Left End
um and another thing that we can do with
the notes is just move them around by
hovering in the center of the note
and then finally the last thing that we
can do is delete the notes by holding
down right click and deleting them
now if you deleted a note that you liked
uh you can you might be tempted to click
controls Z and think that you fixed it
and it's true it does work for one
mistake but let's say I wanted to go
back more than one undo if you want to
go back multiple undo's you're going to
have to hold Ctrl alt Z and this is
something that
uh well it records everything that
you've done on the program will record
up to that point and then by holding off
of alt it'll undo all those things so I
know that's a little confusing it's a
little different than most programs uh
Control Alt Z is undo and then just Ctrl
Z is redo that's the way you have to
think about it for FL it's a little hard
to get used to but that's how that works
the next thing uh I guess we could talk
about is probably selecting multiple
notes at the same time uh if you hold
down control and then left click it'll
bring up the selection menu which allows
you to select a bunch of notes here and
we can move all these at the same time
and then the last tool I think that we
need to know before we start making
Melodies is just the slice tool so right
up here on this row you're going to see
all the tools I've been using so far so
we have the select tool here which I use
control left click as a shortcut you
have the slice tool here which is if you
if you want to know the shortcut I
believe it's
shift right nope
never mind I don't know what it is
that's okay
um you can just use an iPhone up here
and use that to slice
um notes and then that's really helpful
if you're trying to slice many notes at
the same time
and then finally what we have is the
mute tool which allows us to mute notes
you've got a bunch of tools up here that
you can mess around with which will be
really helpful for when you're making
Melodies without further Ado I think
that we should try and make a
corporation we should actually uh start
making a Melody and I think uh the panel
will become more familiar to you as we
keep using it over and over again what
we're going to do is we're just going to
delete these two notes I have over here
and we're going to start off by moving a
note in the range of
see halfway from C3 to probably a little
above C4 I want to make a bass line I'm
going to take a note I'm going to just
click it down here
just like so
and I'm going to stretch it all the way
from the first number one all the way to
two I want it to be one bar long the bar
is going to be from any one number to
the next number is going to say be
signified as one whole bar and so that's
the length I want my notes at this
moment if we click this we're going to
just try to make a baseline so I'm gonna
place a few notes after each other and
we're going to see if we can make a
decent 70 Baseline real quick
foreign
foreign
okay so I made a very simple bass line
and the way I did it was just by placing
a one note after the other and I kept
one rule which allowed me to make sure
that I was making
um pretty good choices and that was I
only placed notes on the highlighted
rows and then the non-highlighted rows
are notes which are going to be off key
this is really helpful for when you're
starting off and you don't know a music
theory it can be really helpful to to
know which notes are the right notes and
which ones are the wrong ones just by
staying in one key for your song here I
as you can see if I just take away these
notes now
it doesn't pop up these highlighted rows
but as you start placing them it I
believe it's three notes is the minimum
it tries to make a Scale based off the
notes you placed and you can see it
keeps changing based off of where you
move the notes and then you can place
those notes in there and it will make
you a scale I'm going to undo all that
for so far and we're going to go back to
what we had before and this is what I
ended up making
[Music]
now I recommend that you guys make your
own bass lines you don't need a copy
mine exactly but if you're struggling to
make one you can uh copy it now I'll
leave it up here and then right after
that we're going to start and try to
make some chords
okay so now we are going to place uh
just one note above each of these
baselines so we're going to take it one
step at a time we have our Baseline laid
out so let's just start by adding one
note at a time to each one of these
just ask yourself does that sound good
or should it be somewhere else
okay that sounds good to me so we can
leave this note here and let's go to the
next chord
Okay cool so we got the first two uh
already sound pretty good and I just
chose those by finding a highlighted row
and just choosing one that I thought
sounded good so we have this so far
foreign
that doesn't sound so good to me so
we're going to move this probably down
that also doesn't sound good let's just
mess around with it until we get
something like
and if you don't want to listen to the
whole thing every time you can actually
left click up in this top row and we'll
move the playlist slider to wherever uh
you want to listen to so like let's move
it just in the middle right here and
play
okay that doesn't sound good now you can
attempt to move it on to a row that's
not highlighted just to see if it sounds
good and it possibly could
so you saw there I actually knew that
when I moved this note to this uh darker
highlighted uh Square it was going to
actually make it a highlighted row
because
um I knew I I know a little bit more
about how the how the key was going to
work so that just comes from experience
but sometimes the key can change and you
can actually put a note on a darker row
and it will actually change it into a
highlighted row because it realizes that
you're using a different scale so that's
something to keep in mind so it's not
always wrong to use the not not
highlighted rows it can actually be
beneficial sometimes
[Music]
listen to this all the way through
perfect okay so I'm gonna add just one
note on top of all these and then we'll
have a good Corporation here
[Music]
could do something like that I'm going
to experiment with a couple other things
and I'll get back once I have something
I like
Okay cool so I made something I liked
here and this is what it sounds like
foreign
[Music]
dramatic the way I did this was I simply
just took uh one step at a time we made
our Baseline then we added one note on
top of it and just made sure that every
step of the way I was making choices
that I was happy with that I thought
sounded good and then by the end of it
you can have a product that you like
sometimes it could be a little bit
daunting to say hey we're going to make
an entire chord progression but if you
just take it one note at a time and just
make sure that one note sounds good
after the other note you can start
building things a lot more quickly and
not worry too much about the big picture
and that's how I was able to make the
score progression because I was just
making sure that every step of the way I
was making choices that I thought
benefited the whole so all right now
that we got our chord progression what I
want to do is start adding some
instruments to this pattern to make it
uh more full so the way I'm going to do
this is I'm going to go back to my
channel rack up here and I'm going to
click the plus icon and we're going to
add in another instance of Flex from
here what we're going to do is we're
going to navigate to another instrument
which can act as a baseline for our
chord progression so I'm going to go to
the string section here and I'm just
going to choose the base sustain preset
because I think that will be a good base
for our chord progression so I'm going
to click the X icon here
and then right now if we go back to our
Channel rack from before you can see
that we now have a second instrument
um um in our Channel rack so we have the
closed grand piano and we have our bass
sustain so the way that we can start
adding notes to the base of stain to our
um initial pattern with the chord
progression is by going back to the
piano roll here and clicking up in this
little drop down menu you're going to
see that you can choose the other
instrument so I'm going to click base
sustain
and then we'll be in the uh instrument
base sustain but in the same pattern so
if I click play we're still going to
hear the piano but now when I put a new
note it's going to make the bass sound
as you can see that right there so what
we're going to do is if you don't see
these uh Ghost Notes right here we need
to go up to this corner and go to view
and then make sure ghost channels are
enabled if I disable that you'll see
that these notes disappear and you can't
see where your other instruments and
notes are and so I find it pretty
helpful to have the ghost channels
enabled that way I can always see where
I need to place my notes
so the next question we have to ask
ourselves is where we are going to place
the base notes and for this
um I'm going to navigate back to the
piano
and I'm just going to copy all the lower
notes on our chord progression and use
those as the base notes for our string
section so the way I'm going to do that
is I'm going to hold Ctrl shift and then
I'm just going to hover over and using
left click and I'm just going to while
I'm holding Ctrl shift I'm just going to
select each one of these notes
like so and sometimes it can be a little
bit weird and you'll have to click the
note I don't know why it does that but
sometimes it could be a little finicky
but uh hit Ctrl C once you have all
those selected and then we're going to
navigate back to the base section and
click Ctrl V and if all is well it
should pop up right in the exact same
spots and if it's a little bit off you
can just move those to make sure they're
on properly now let's assume what that
sounds like
[Applause]
awesome so now we have a base section
which we can use to supplement our chord
progression from here I'd like to add a
melody on top of our Corporation and I
think that that will really get us in a
position where we can start working with
patterns in the next chapter
so what we're going to do to make a
Melody is go back to our Channel rack
right here and we're going to hit the
plus icon again and we are going to go
back to flex you guessed it and we're
going to find something that can make us
a good
um a good instrument for a Melody so I'm
going to navigate to maybe
not exactly sure maybe you could do like
a wind instrument
not exactly what we want and sure what
we want here but
technically doesn't matter what we pick
I'll just do a tuba I don't know why but
we'll just use a tuba why not so from
here uh we're just going to navigate to
the tuba instrument
and then if I click a note you'll hear
the this instrument
and I'm just gonna make these notes a
lot shorter so I'm going to drag this
here make it smaller
and let's just make a a rhythm for our
Melody so the way I go about making my
Melodies is I want to keep the Rhythm
consistent to give you guys an example
let's just play a rhythm here
by clicking in some notes
[Music]
and then I'm going to just control click
copy and then I'm going to shift click
this and we'll duplicate it and then
shift click again duplicate shift click
duplicate you don't you don't have to do
this right now basically I'm just
showing you guys this to teach you guys
how I think about my Melodies when I'm
making music so let's listen to what
this sounds like
[Music]
Okay cool so right here what we have is
we have every single bar we are playing
the same Rhythm so we have one note one
note one note and then two smaller ones
and then as you can see the pattern
repeats itself and this in the
listener's ear is going to create a
pattern in the memory which will make it
so it doesn't sound like the melody is
all over the place because they can they
can hold on to a rhythm which is it's
catchy this is what makes it catchy but
it it becomes repetitive if I just have
this on one note so to make a Melody not
repetitive you need to keep the same
Rhythm or at least keep it moderately
similar and then you have to change the
notes in ways that are uh and this this
comes a little bit with time is you kind
of know how to change it in a way that
doesn't sound too chaotic but a way that
sounds enough to give the listener
something interesting to listen to so
why don't we start by moving these notes
around like this like I'm gonna just
move this one a little bit down
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
and then maybe we don't have these two
notes Here we just we just delete them
and then so to copy this I want so okay
the way I think about this is kind of
fractally if you if you've ever seen
fractals before you know how they kind
of like you can zoom in and it's the
same pattern and you can zoom out and
you see a bigger pattern and so I think
about Melodies In a fractal way it
really helps me think about how I want
things on the bigger and smaller scale
looking like a cohesive hole so the way
that I'm going to do this is I you see
how I have the I at first I had the
Rhythm exactly the same for each bar and
then in the second bar right here I
deleted these last two endnotes so what
am I going to gonna do for the fourth
bar I'm also going to delete these two
endnotes because it matches the the
second bar so I if you if you right
click on this bar with the numbers you
can actually uh highlight a section
which will repeat itself so if I click
play here
foreign
so I'm going to be doing this often to
show you guys the way I'm thinking about
my Melodies so in this case you can see
at first I Had Each bar repeating the
Rhythm exactly the same which was
initially this this pattern right here
which I
um
[Music]
and I repeated that four times now as
you can see I have a rhythm which is two
bars Long
and and you're probably wondering why is
it two bars Long well remember I made
that change on the second bar where I
took off these notes and then this
entire pattern repeats itself because on
this second bar I also take off these
two notes and if you need to remember
what a bar is it's from this number to
this number so these two bars act as a
one big pattern and then that the second
two bars repeat this first two bars
pattern okay hopefully you guys are are
not having too much trouble uh following
along a lot of the stuff I don't know
because I can write it on a piece of
paper or because I read it in a book
it's it's trying to explain to you the
type of things that you learn by
experience and these things are very
difficult to kind of like condensate in
the words at times so I'm sorry if it
sounds like a little bit confusing I'm
really trying to boil down like what's
going on subconsciously to you guys and
it can be difficult sometimes so
oh I think it really it comes from
making a lot of bad Melodies over and
over again and then noticing just one
thing that made the melody sound good
and then remembering that for next time
and then over time you build up these
experiences which allow you to make uh
helpful and good changes to your music
and so sometimes even when I'm doing a
full course like this I can I can sort
of walk you through what I'm doing but
you are going to have to try to make
your own Melodies you are going to have
to make a lot of bad Melodies to really
understand like how to make good
Melodies and that's just how everything
in life is you really just need to put
in time and experience in these things
so if you're struggling off the bat
don't worry I I didn't have I didn't
even know about Rhythm or anything when
I was making Melodies I was just
clicking notes all over the place and
actually sound kind of good but I was
placing those all over the place and
yeah it was just really bad so if even
if you start with this bear it just uh
like if you get 10 out of what I'm
saying about Melodies right now you'll
already be ahead of where I was when I
started so just I think you it it's when
it's not complicated now but I think
you're it you'll be okay if you if you
just take a little bit away from this
even if you don't understand everything
I'm saying so in the second half of the
melody what I'm going to do is I want to
repeat the third bar I want to repeat in
the first bar so I'm just going to copy
the notes honestly
[Music]
okay and then in the second part I
already know what I want to do so what I
want to do is I just want to have it
something like that maybe Okay let's
listen to what this sounds like
[Music]
so what was my thought process and how
did I make a Melody without even
listening to it and knowing that it
would sound good how what are the rules
that I employed to get something that
was going to sound decent no matter what
the way I think about these Melodies is
that I have a structure which I apply
and it applies to the Rhythm but it also
applies to the pitch of the notes so
this is called a a b a c Melody okay so
from bar one to two this is a from bars
two to three this is B
from bars three to four that's a and
from bars four to five that's C and so
why is it called a b a c well because
a matches the a here matches this a
right here
and the C matches in rhythm
I mean the B matches in Rhythm C however
it differs in where the notes are placed
okay and so it could technically you
could say that this is a
a b a b because the Rhythm doesn't
change from two and four but I'm just
saying it's a b a c because I change the
notes that may not be technically
correct but hopefully you're following
along with my thought processor so what
do I do I don't want the listener to be
all over the place if I want the
listener to be all over the place here's
what I do
[Music]
okay we're going to do this as an
example to show you how Melodies can get
confusing so I didn't put anything on
any wrong notes I didn't actually choose
any specifically wrong notes in this
melody okay I know I'm technically
putting one on this darker highlighted
don't worry about that that's
technically not an incorrect no I can
explain that later but just roll with me
so
so nothing's wrong about this it's just
hard to follow okay because it doesn't
repeat itself in any meaningful way
there's no pattern here like sure some
of the Rhythm stays the same but it's
it's very difficult to follow and
there's there's lots of wrong things
about this melody and I use wrong in
quotations because you can get a lot
away with a lot of stuff in music okay
so let's talk about why this melody
doesn't work okay why doesn't this
melody not work sure
a lot of the Rhythm stays the same like
you always have it start with three
um Quarter Bar note lengths and you have
that here
and then you also have that here
I hate that note
okay so we have that continuity okay so
it has somewhat of a pattern right but
what's the problem it doesn't repeat the
same pattern ever like it's always
playing different notes so there's
nothing that stays the same so this is
fantastic right here because it may not
be like a like a hit song Melody but it
sounds good it sounds good enough
because you have these two things
repeating each other so I have a little
bit of of continuity so you can kind of
hear a pattern in your head
[Music]
okay so I could even if I didn't want to
repeat exactly I could do something like
this I could
this might not sound as good but you
could try something like this
like yeah that works too but like you
see how like
the closer you can keep it while only
making slight changes you have to this
is where that you you have this balance
right this balance between novelty and
Chaos because you want it to sound well
you have it's like novelty boring and
Chaos okay something like that you have
like this three thing going on because
it could either be all over the place
where nothing makes sense you either
have everything super boring and The
Listener like wants to turn off your
song or you have to strike this medium
where you're doing something that's
interesting without making the listener
feel like they have no idea where they
are okay and then this is something that
like I said it's going to take feel it's
going to take time and you are going to
have to mess up and you have to be okay
with messing up okay so
yeah I Melodies are gonna be though are
always going to be difficult because no
matter I've seen producers that are
professionals people who know the
software front to back and they cannot
make a Melody to save their life and
that's okay okay they're fantastic
producers in a lot of different ways but
Melodies are something that
not everyone gets but if you put in time
and effort and if you're really
struggling if you I would recommend
learning a little bit of music theory
and that can also benefit you if you
don't have it as much of a natural
musical ear for Melodies but yeah so I
just don't want you guys to be
discouraged because once we hit Melodies
that I knew this was going to be in
Melodies and chords especially these
things can take a long time to develop
an ear for and honestly I can't give you
guys the rules for everything I can't do
the exact steps on how to become a music
producer because there are no exact
steps to becoming a music producer it's
a non-linear process the best I can do
is teach you the steps on how to use the
tools how to navigate the tools and try
to give you the best advice I can to try
to get you in a place to where you can
have the type of mindset to where you
can do these things
um okay hopefully I'm not rambling for
too long I just really wanted to
encourage you guys uh because I know
that making Melodies is difficult and I
know I'm making courses difficult and I
just didn't want somebody watching this
video to feel like they were really
struggling and watching me make these
chords and Melodies and they're like I
don't know what this guy's doing I can't
do this I'm I suck at music production
please don't quit please don't quit if
you if you didn't have a corporation or
Melody figured out yet it's okay okay
just copy the one I have and we can move
from there I want you guys to have
something finished even if it is someone
of mine maybe you could change it and
just tweak it in a few different ways to
make it something your own and that's
fine but like
yeah I just don't want you guys to get
discouraged because I know I'm throwing
a lot at you and that's there's a lot
more that we have to go through so
hopefully you guys can stick around and
this wasn't too much so let's move on to
the next section and just uh try to take
a little bit more slowly the next
section is going to be easier so it'll
give you a little bit of a breather from
working on more difficult uh making
Melodies that can be quite quite
tiresome if you're struggling with it so
uh without further Ado let's move on to
the next chapter
foreign
I'm really excited because I remember in
the last chapter I mentioned the way
that uh I think about music production
in a fractal way and so I want to show
you guys why I think a music production
like this and to do this what we're
going to do is go to this square right
here that's the left of the piano roll
so remember we have our Channel rack
here left of the channel rack is our
piano roll and left of the piano roll is
our playlist and the playlist is very
similar to the piano roll in a lot of
ways and you'll see this immediately
because we can still use this top bar to
navigate left and right just like the
panel roll same with the vertical bar
same with uh increasing horizontally and
increasing vertically so it has the same
controls the navigation as a piano roll
but what type of notes are we going to
be placing in here well the thing is
this is not uh where we're placing notes
this is actually where we're placing our
patterns so the pattern that we made
with our all the instruments I can
actually click in here
and then you remember when I clicked uh
I changed it from song to pattern up in
this play button now if I click it on
song it's going to take the it's
actually going to play our pattern here
so that's what that the that's what the
distinction is between these different
types of play buttons so if I go to song
and I click play or space bar
[Music]
what the playlist is used for this is
where we are taking our patterns this is
where the music gets made essentially
this is where everything happens so I'm
going to show you guys a super cool
trick which is going to allow you to
make things really quickly so I already
showed you how to use one pattern to
make
um all the different
um instruments fit together into a
cohesive whole but you're probably
thinking right now okay Tristan how am I
going to do anything all my instruments
are bunched together in this like same
pattern what am I going to do
I understand that so what we're going to
do is we're going to right click the
pattern one and we're going to go to
split by Channel and what this is going
to do is that this is going to split and
name for us all of our instruments that
we have so now they're all kind of laid
on top of each other so we're just going
to delete all of them okay and if we
click this and add it in here then click
this one add it in and click this one
and add it in now we can see each one of
these is actually one of the patterns
that we made from before and it split it
up for us essentially
so now like for instance I could take
out the piano
maybe I want to undo that and I want to
take the melody
and hopefully this is very intuitive and
you can see how many parallels there are
to the piano roll so just like in the
piano roll I could click a second one
and I could repeat the pattern over
again
and maybe uh later in the song I want
all the instruments to come together but
earlier in the song I I don't want as
many elements together maybe that's how
I want my song to be and so what I'm
going to do is I'm actually just going
to restructure this so I'm going to hold
shift and middle Mouse scroll wheel and
I'm just going to move this melody to
the top I I like to have my Melodies on
top my chords in the middle and my bass
lower because I'm pretty OCD and I like
things to be organized so this is an
easy way for me to organize things so
again that was just holding shift
hovering over where it says track one or
whichever one you want to move uh for me
was track one and if it's just scroll
wheel I can actually move this up and
down it's a quick little it's just a
quick little uh shortcut you don't need
to remember this it's something that is
not necessary it's just something I do
to organize stuff fast so right here
let's just listen to what we have in our
playlist so I was just clicking I was
literally just clicking these patterns
right here these are all the patterns
that we made I was just clicking them in
just like notes Okay so
this is just the basics of how we can
lay out in our playlist different by the
way this is what this is called so the
piano roll is where we put the notes in
and where we where we click in notes and
then the playlist is where we click in
patterns so and it's the same controls
so just like you can split notes you can
also split patterns so it's it's
literally the exact same thing as the
piano roll it's just applied to the
entire pattern so hopefully that's
that's helpful for you guys to
understand
um I guess the one thing I didn't really
explain is that right here this is in
this like row this is where all your
patterns are stored so before we just
had one pattern and so that's why there
was no reason to come to the playlist
because everything that you were working
with was in the panel roll but now since
I split everything up if I double click
on any of them it's going to open back
up the piano roll and it's just going to
open up this instrument you can see here
that if I go back to my base my base
isn't here anymore and my melody isn't
here because these patterns are
separated now I separated them into
separate ones so if I click on the tuba
you can see that the two has a check
mark because that's the only and these
don't have check marks because there's
no notes in them but I want you to take
away from this chapter is just the
similarities between the playlist and
between the piano roll and I hopefully
by connecting these two different parts
of the software and seeing the
similarities between them it should
become pretty apparent in in your head
how they're connected and you can see
how a full song could be made the
playlist is just for where you put
together you saw where you take all the
patterns and all the Melodies and chords
and everything and where you lay it out
into a finished uh finished product
that's going to be telling a story to
the listener if you get that you
understand the playlist so without
further Ado why don't we go to the next
section and start working on what
samples are
thank you
in this chapter we're going to be going
over samples a sample is just a sound
file that can come in as a wave or MP3
and this is going to be used for
something like recording vocals through
a mic you'll be recording into a sample
or recording voice memos on your phone
or anything of that sort so the way that
we're going to use samples is by
accessing the Fuller system in FL Studio
so if you look to our left right here we
have this browser column right here you
can see its browser and you have all
these folders here now I already
imported a lot of folders with my own
samples so you guys aren't going to have
a lot of these however if you open up
packs right here this is where you are
going to find the default FL Studio
samples so why don't we navigate here
and just click through these folders
until we find a sample that we can add
into our track that way you guys can
understand uh what they are for so
I'm just going to click on kicks and uh
right here you can see there's this
little new icon and this indicates that
you're clicking on a sample so let's
click on a few of these and listen to
what they sound like
[Music]
all right cool so I'm going to use FPC
5K and I'm just going to left click hold
and I'm going to drag it into my project
and you can see there's this little gray
highlighted area where I'm hovering with
my mouse and if I just let go anywhere I
want it's going to place this sample so
this sample is going to play uh just
like a note in our panel would except
that now it's going to play this sound
file once it reaches this point in the
song so for instance if we listen here
foreign
so that sounded pretty random and out of
place so why don't we find a place to
put our kick that actually makes sense
in the song and start making it into a
type of pattern which would make sense
so there are two ways that we could
place this kick in our song I could for
one I could delete this right here and I
could go and create a new pattern before
I click the new pattern I just want to
make a one note so before in this column
over here you'd remember that are all of
our patterns popped up in this column
but now all you see is the sample the
FPC kick 5 kick that we added in this is
because there are multiple icons here
which indicate which
um storage unit you're essentially
looking at so this middle icon is for
samples like the one that we just
Dragged In and this left icon right here
is going to show us our samples our uh
my bad our patterns so if we click here
I can click on one of these and add in
as you can see that specific pattern so
if I go back here and click on that I
can add in my sample again so that's
just helpful to remember if you ever get
lost or forget which one's which that's
where that is so what we're going to do
is we're going to go back to our pattern
and we're going to click the plus icon
here and this is a good point in which
you can learn how to manually name our
patterns just in case you want to do
that and you don't want to split it like
I showed you earlier so let's just name
this drums
if I can spell properly drums there we
go and also why don't we just make it a
different color just to show you guys
how you could do this you can just drag
this any color you want and then it will
pop up as that color make sure you hit
the check icon right here
and then boom it's going to make our
pattern and it's going to make it a
specific color as well so this gets into
color coding and this is this can be
really fun too to do I don't do it too
often since it takes extra time but if I
finish a project and I have nothing else
to do sometimes I'll go back over it and
make it look nice so
let's
um before we double click into here what
we're going to want to do is go up to
our Channel rack right here
and you can see that from when we add in
our sample it actually shows us the
sample right here in our
um Channel rack so to see our
instruments from before we need to go to
this top bar right here and click all
and now this is going to show all of our
instruments and our kick so there's a
couple different
um there's a couple different options we
have unsorted which shows us essentially
the instruments that aren't sorted yet
and then we have audio and it shows us
our samples and then we have all and
then this shows us all the different
things that we've added into our project
you might be wondering okay what else
goes in the channel rack the only thing
that's going to appear in our chain rack
that we haven't gone over yet is
automations so automations samples and
instruments are the three things that
are stored in your channel rack and
we'll go over that eventually but for
right now we only need to focus on
samples so the way we're going to
approach this is we're going to right
click on the sample and we're going to
go to piano roll
and now in the piano roll because we
were selected on the drum pattern from
before we'll be placing our our kick in
the drum pattern so let's go back to the
playlist just to reiterate what I just
did so back in patterns over here I have
selected the drums I go to my channel
rack and then I can right click and if
this is checked it's not going to go
into the piano so you have to uncheck it
and then check it again
and now we will be in our drum pattern
with the specific sample that we have so
I I was debating whether or not to show
you guys this but I am going to show you
the way uh doing it like this even
though I don't do it myself so you may
be wondering like wow this is extremely
confusing and I don't really want to put
in samples like this
um if you're thinking that uh and you
don't want to do it this method then
that's fine if you'd like to keep
everything in patterns I'm going to show
you this method just so that you have
another uh way of producing that I know
some people enjoy more
um so just so I can give the full
breadth of how you can use FL Studio
because not all producers produce the
same what we can do here is just place a
kick
and as you can see the kick actually it
pitches up and down the sample
um depending on where we place the note
so that's also pretty cool feature P5 is
going to be the default pitch of the
sample just so you guys know I'm going
to place a kick right on the first beat
on the I'm going to place it midway
between one and two and then I'm gonna
place it on actually you know what let's
leave it like that and I'll show you
guys a little trick here so what could
we do I could keep keep going with this
pattern like this
but if I know I'm already going to do
that pattern well there's no sense in me
uh manually drawing in the notes I can
just do this I could take the pattern
shorten it down
and then copy it
just like that and so this is a way that
that if you did it like this it would
save you a lot of time save even more
time we can navigate if you remember the
tools that we have up here we can use
the paint tool and paint across just
like that we have our entire drum
pattern across and so let's listen to
what we have right now
[Music]
okay I think that we should take out the
kick right here I'm actually going to
right click on this sample and we're
going to take out the kick here and
we're only going to leave it for the
second half right here and what I want
to do is I want to add in a different
sample so I'm going to add in a snare
and the snare is going to be our pattern
right here so let's find a snare that
sounds good
now if you're looking for sample and
it's slow to click every single one you
can also use the arrow keys on your
keyboard to quickly filter through them
[Music]
so I found a sample that I like
simple and it's not too too crazy so
we're going to use the sample and this
time rather than making a pattern I'm
gonna show you guys the other ways that
you can use samples we're just going to
click the sample in so now I can just
click the sample as if it's a note see
I'm selected back on my sample right
here and so if I click this one I can
actually just click and place every uh
every spot I want to sample so I'm going
to zoom in here to make sure I'm placing
it in the correct spot
see I have it when I have it in the
right spot here so let's click click it
here
I believe that's also off a little bit
okay
and that should be pretty close Okay
let's listen to this
[Music]
Okay cool so we have wait I actually
is this off I can't tell
okay there we go I fixed it my bad
um all right so what we're going to do
is I'm going to take this I'm going to
select all of these and I'm going to
hold shift and we're going to go down
arrow so I'm just again I'm going to be
using shortcuts and speaking as I use
the shortcut to show you guys how I'm
doing things quicker
um because I noticed when I was
recording these tutorials before I would
use a lot of shortcuts that I are just
like wired in because I know how to move
around the software really quick but
then I wouldn't explain how I did that
so oh I was right the first time okay
never mind
um yes but I would use the shortcuts
without explaining them so sorry if
explaining the shortcuts is taking a
little extra I want to make sure that
you guys know where I'm going in the
software
um okay so what I'm going to do here is
I'm just going to copy these and there's
a couple ways I could copy and paste
these across my song I could hold shift
like I did before and shows you guys
with the piano notes and just shift
click it across and this method works
perfectly fine
however there's also another method I
could use if I can also right click
select this bar and if you remember what
this does it repeats whatever section of
the song I selected here so
we could listen to this over and over
again uh but if I actually select all
everything that I want from the section
of song and hit Ctrl B for duplicate not
duplicate duplicate it's going to
duplicate it one section over I don't
really know how to explain it but you
just get used to doing this a lot and
this is the way I copy and paste things
throughout my song extremely quickly and
yes so that is another method that you
can use to copy pastings across yourself
so I'm hoping that what will happen is
if I give you I guess enough enough
methods of doing things in the software
you'll latch on to like one or two that
you like and you're like oh I like the
way that he did that I want to remember
that for later and then you can just
come back to this video anytime that you
need and just remember what that is and
then be able to practice it that way you
can be able to use it so that's my
intention let's listen to what we have
so far just to see what kind of progress
we're making
[Music]
now that we've done samples I think it's
time to go to our next chapter and then
we can start fleshing this out a bit
more so let's go
[Music]
okay so the plan here is to essentially
take all the chapters that we've learned
thus far and just repeat them over and
over again until we can actually fill up
and turn this into a more full song so I
don't just go through these processes
one time through making a song I know I
said at the beginning of the course
you're going to be using all these but
you are also going to be using them
multiple times over so like when I
showed you to open up the channel rack
to add an instrument and then layer
maybe I don't just want one piano maybe
I want two pianos stacked on top of each
other I'm going to show you guys in the
channel rack right here if remember our
piano is called close Grand or whichever
one you choose navigate to that one and
then you're going to right click on this
piano and then hit clone
and right here it's going to duplicate
our piano instrument and so here we see
that we have the same Flex plug-in that
automatically opened and showing us
different uh the piano that we chose
again so I'm going to choose a different
piano sound here and we're just going to
mess around with some stuff so
Okay cool so we have this piano sound
I'm going to exit out we're going to
double click on our close Grand pattern
and it's going to open it back up for us
uh Ctrl C
and then navigate up here and we're
going to go to electric piano and then
Ctrl V okay hopefully you guys are
following along and then if we play
see that's way more interesting so we
just added just one more instrument and
it just added just a little bit to to
what's going on here so
I think that that that's cool
um we could do this again so I'm going
to duplicate the electric piano again
and then we can add a string instrument
so why don't we add like all strings
slow for instance we could just
mess around with this and then I'm going
to show you guys a super fast method for
copying and pasting the chords so you
see where we have in our Channel rack
it's if it's showing you the Beats like
this you can just click off of that and
it'll show you uh just make sure you can
see these these patterns right here
um what you're going to want to do is
click on the Square so you see we have
the pattern here so if I double click
this it's going to open the pattern
electric piano if I double click this
it's going to open up the pattern to my
close Grant but you see the pattern here
it opens up nothing because there's no
pattern in there so what we can do to
copy quickly copy and paste is hit Ctrl
C on this little this little green
square right here you just click it left
click the screen Square Ctrl C and then
click on the instrument that you want to
paste it into and Ctrl V and then boom
it's going to paste the uh the same
course in there so we don't have to
manually go in so let's listen to this
foreign
[Music]
already sounding way better just by
adding a few more instruments it's
really adding a lot I think okay so we
have this base uh I don't want to listen
to all these instruments at the same
time anymore I want to listen to Just
the bass so what we're going to do first
is I'm going to exit out of the channel
rack I'm going to control left click
select all of my instruments here then
I'm going to use the shift key down
arrow a couple times I want to give
myself some room
and then we're going to click on the
close Grant because if you remember this
is where we added our new instruments so
why don't we split this again so I'm
going to right click on it and I'm going
to split by Channel and then right here
I just got all my instruments again
right here
so as you can see it split our I'm just
left clicking and dragging it actually
puts all the patterns on top of each
other sort of annoying but it's all
right and so I miscounted here so just
on track five right click delete that
track boom and that's just gonna delete
make sure there was nothing in it and
once you delete that we got this here so
right now if I right click on any of
these green dots you can actually hear
just this individual pattern
foreign
Okay cool so I think that would be
really uh neat is if we uh just listen
to this part so far uh of this song So a
right click and then drag uh just on
this this four bar pattern so one two
three four these four bars
um and then I'm going to right click on
this dot again it's going to unmute all
of them and then we can just assume
okay cool I'm gonna double click the
electric piano I'm gonna go in here and
then I'm going to start changing some of
the notes in here so I want this to be
more of like an an ARP so we're going to
start from the lowest note and we're
going to keep that the same so we have
oh that's fine uh the next note I'm
gonna go here I'm just and basically
this is just me from messing around with
stuff just saying okay what would sound
cool if like I've changed some stuff and
this like you uh you need to give
yourself permission to mess around like
to mess stuff up and if you say Okay
Tristan I want to follow along with the
tutorial though and I don't want to mess
up something if you want to try
something uh what you can do is you can
actually go up to here and click save as
new version and I do this all the time
so what I'll do is like for instance
okay let's say I have this version of
the song where it sounds like this
and I'm like I want to make a major
change to the song what I can do is go
up to file save as new version and what
that's going to do is create a duplicate
copy of the entire project where I can
mess around on this and I still have the
other copy here so I still have my
tutorial one right there boom I still
have that so that project file just
sitting right there so you can always go
back to it so um now that we made this
new project all right made this
duplicate project I feel completely
comfortable messing around because it's
not going to affect the other project
that I was happy with so
here I'm going to change I'm just going
to make some creative uh decisions here
so I'm going to take these notes and I'm
going to just incrementally do this
[Music]
foreign
so I'm actually going to delete that top
note because I think it would sound
better like this and so I'm just going
to have I'm gonna have a little walking
motion so you see how from in this bar
it's divided into four segments you have
one two three four and so I'm putting a
note walking up the stairs sort of like
so each one is going incrementally one
quarter of a bar up to the next note
and then I'm gonna do the exact same
thing here so I'm going to add a note
here I think that would probably sound
good and I'm pretty much just guessing
at this point we'll see if it does
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
okay so right now I just was messing
around with notes just listening to it
over and over and I have it repeating
remember if I go back to my playlist by
clicking here I select this this portion
of the song that way I could listen to
it over and over
and listen to How The Melodies play out
in this in this part of the song so if
you see the changes I made I I didn't
have to talk exactly because I'm just
messing around and I put some notes in
places I didn't like and I deleted them
and I just changed them and I just kind
of made incremental changes to until I
came up with something I was happy with
so
um and really I didn't have any Rhyme or
reasons like what I was doing it's
mostly just like intuition just clicking
okay this is the highlighted note let's
click here and see if it sounds good
doesn't sound good okay put it on
different note and just take your time
with stuff and see what sounds good so
um some tips I can give to make Melodies
and Arps that sound good is I made sure
that I didn't have different uh rhythms
uh for the entire thing so as I said
before the pattern that this is
following is just exactly
it's literally this it never changes
Rhythm so it's always doing one quarter
bar note that's the length of every
single note you can see here that the
length between each note that plays is
exactly one quarter bar so I kept that
consistent through the whole thing
so I was able to change uh everything on
top that was happening and it would
sound uh decent so another thing that
you can see that I did is I kept the
bass notes always starting as the first
note that hit
um and so that was something that I also
kept consistent uh and you can see here
I just had the top note uh also hit with
the bass note because I thought it
sounded good so and yeah there's not you
can notice that I okay so this is
something interesting so you can see
that here on the second bar and on the
fourth bar I decided to have the top
notes hit and you can see how there's a
pattern there because on the first and
third I have the second lowest note
that's the first to play and on the
second and fourth I have the highest
note so you can see there's a pattern
there so uh what's funny is that like
when I'm making Melodies my intuition
will do things that makes sense and then
I can go back and analyze and go oh yeah
that's why this works because they have
this is a pattern with this and then
this is a pattern with this and then
that's why it works
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this melody if you remember before uh
with the lettering system would be a a b
a b melody or I guess it would be a b
a yeah a b a c because this is different
well they're all different but
if you think about it melodically wise I
would say it's an A B
AC I think I really don't know how that
works but I cut roughly roughly get it
okay anyways so we got something like
this uh we can mess around so I could I
could go control up arrow and just see
what sounds like a octaphar
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I think that sounds good
and you know what maybe we want to add
um okay so I like the way this is going
I think I want to add another uh bass
instrument here so I'm just going to do
the same thing I'm just gonna take this
down drop it an octave go to my channel
rack find the base of stain that's my
instrument here make sure it's set to
all up here just in case you don't see
it everything right click on the base
clone
and it's going to clone my instrument
and I just find a different base here so
I'm going to go to wins because I think
it'd be cool to have some type of brass
instrument like a little
that could be cool so let's try it
um if I click on my base pattern here I
don't double click I just single click
and then go to my channel rack it's
going to show me that pattern and
remember what I did before Ctrl C copy
that pattern paste it on the new
instrument I just cloned boom and then
we have that clone so now if I listen
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
okay so we hear a problem which is
happening I'm adding a bunch of
instruments and you hear how it's
getting a little bit loud and it's
actually kind of hard to hear some of
the instruments because you keep adding
more how can we fix this so This is
actually going to get into I don't know
if it's our next chapter that we're
going to do leveling I think it might
actually be yeah it is our next chapter
okay so this is a perfect segue into our
next chapter where I can show you guys
briefly what we're going to do to fix
this problem that we run into once we
keep adding sounds we actually run into
a problem is that everything is getting
too loud so before we head on to the
next chapter I'm just quickly going to
split this uh Again by right clicking on
the bass sustain including split by
Channel and then that's going to give me
my bra sound here which I can just make
sure that I have right here and now I
have all my instruments and all my
patterns laid out and named
um if you guys want to color them it's
up to you uh and hopefully you're able
to follow along I know I'm going a lot
quicker now because I've already gone
over all the steps initially to show you
how to do these things so I'm hopefully
I don't want to repeat myself too many
times so what I'm hoping is that if you
guys get lost into one something that
I'm doing here you can always go back to
the chapter where I explain it in depth
and then you come back and uh just see
how I did it again so hopefully uh I
know I went quicker this chapter but
hopefully you guys are still able to
follow along now let's get to fixing the
volume problem
[Music]
okay so now we're going to take care of
this volume issue it gets very loud once
we get to the ninth bar here as you can
see because we have the most instruments
playing at the same time so how do we
change the volume on a very quick basis
to just make sure that things sound uh
the way that they should
the way that we're going to do that is
we're going to go to the channel rack
and as you can see we have these little
um uh things right here which are these
little levers which allow us to turn
them if I left click and drag it will
let me change the volume so it's very
simple so like let's say I go right
click on all strings slow and then we
see all strings flow right here if I
listen to it
and then I muted it
so I want to decide how loud do I want
this and so you never want to change the
volume of an instrument individually
okay so what do I mean by that I mean
that you should listen to everything in
the song at the same time while you're
changing the volume to see how it sounds
as a whole because you're not listening
to One instrument you're listening to a
whole song so that's why you want to
change the volume of everything so let's
listen to everything and change the
volume as we find needed
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
moving these volume knobs around I was
just messing around with it and I think
it sounds a lot better already so you
might be wondering so what exactly is
are these knobs on the left right here
these knobs are for painting so let's
listen to what this sounds like if I
panicked
actually I think it'd be helpful if I
just solo just so you could guys can
hear what it's doing
foreign
to our right and left ears here so I'm
going to make the close Grand at the
center so if you ever need to reset
these for any reason just right click on
it and click reset and then we'll reset
it so if I turn it here and then click
reset it'll bring it back to the middle
so just a little helpful thing just in
case you messed up something and you
wanted it back the way it was
um I think that the electric painted
would sound good sort of more towards
the right ear so let's pan this a little
bit to the right just a little bit and
then the strings we can have a little
bit to the left and see how this sounds
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
a lot better okay I'm actually going to
change the tube instrument because I
think it sounds weird so why don't we go
here and just
why what would be interesting why don't
we go to a guitar instrument and just
try out some of these guitars
and then obviously we want to listen to
The Melody so I'm just going to
highlight this part and I'm going to
highlight one chord before the melody
hits because I want to see how it comes
in too
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay I think that the electric piano
actually takes a lot away when this
Melody comes in so what if we took out
the strings and the electric piano here
just by right clicking and see what this
sounds like
okay I think that we do need the
electric piano in there but I don't like
that both these actually maybe it's okay
that The Melodies are playing maybe I
can just make it quieter
um I guess I'll make the ultran just
slightly quieter for now that's one way
we can do that
okay
I I think it sounded cool and I like the
guitar more than the tuba
um and basically that is just leveling
so it's really simple the chapter is not
too crazy it's just basically just
changing the volume and I even threw in
panting in here wasn't gonna do that but
I guess we're doing that that's okay
um so yeah volume and painting this is
very uh very simple stuff so you can
just use that if it gets too loud if the
entire project itself you're like this
entire thing is too loud for me to
listen to all you have to do is go up
while you're listening and you can turn
this volume
just down like that
and that this changes the entire volume
of the entire track and there's a couple
other things up here that maybe we could
go over now uh we have another uh
another option up here called BPM uh so
this is going to change the beats per
minute of the song so if I don't hover
over the right side of these tiny
numbers but over the left side and you
can see
it slows down our song or it can speed
it up
see so like I I had it at 140 initially
so I'm going to keep it there but um
yeah you could change the BPM if you
don't like the BPM and then this is the
master pitch I never use this but it's
here
foreign
I have an idea for this later we might
try something with that
um okay well now that the chapters are
we're going to move on to the next
chapter and I will see you guys there
[Music]
okay awesome so I think that what we can
do here is just work on a chorus for the
song So this isn't necessarily this is
going to be another uh fleshing out
chapter so I have I have a lot of
chapters where like it's going to be
over a certain part but I'm realizing
that I need more where I'm just actually
working on the song so I think what
would be really neat is if we have the
drums sort of kind of uh getting a
little bit more intense here and then
building up into some sort of like
chorus that could be interesting and
unique here so why don't we have the
drums start building up building up here
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
interesting
um okay so I'm trying to think about
what I want to do here let's go to Pax
and snares
[Music]
please
foreign
we're gonna make a
you know what we're gonna go over
everything so I'm kind of uh at first we
were kind of making something like some
orchestral stuff uh and I never make
this type of music this is just
something that I guess just sort of
happened as I was just making stuff
um but like what if you wanted to make
EDM music I have no idea what you guys
would make maybe you want to make
hip-hop so why don't we just start
making some different genres in the song
I'm not exactly sure what you guys are
going to want to make so we'll just kind
of do everything so how about uh here's
here's kind of my plan for this song I'm
not sure exactly what you guys think but
I'm gonna have it be this kind of
orchestral intro and then it's going to
drop into some like EDM drop randomly
this would be really weird
and then after the EDM drop we can go
into like some hip-hop uh and then maybe
just close that like that and then we
can go to the next chapter where we're
going to start building this uh all
together so this chapter this could just
be lengthy I I guess uh this chapter I'm
gonna take the most time and I'm just
gonna start working on different parts
of songs so uh what I want is you you
know when you hear EDM songs they always
have like that build up it's like and
then it goes up faster and faster we
need that so we're gonna put the snare
here
[Music]
that's perfect so we're just gonna turn
down the volume of the snare by double
clicking the sample
um I'm not oh you know what my bad I
deleted this video I had a part in the
course where I was showing you guys how
to do this my bad I forgot to include it
okay so this is something I I should
just briefly cover so when you add a
sample in here and you need to change
the volume of a sample really quickly
there's a fast way of doing that too now
yes you could go to the channel rack and
turn it down here that's true
um I just find myself more often than
not uh actually changing the volume here
and okay so this is actually kind of
confusing so if I double click the
sample here and I change the volume here
it's it actually does change the volume
there so
yes uh there's a lot of these knobs in
FL Studio are kind of linked so it's
just whichever one you find yourself
using more often
I find it faster to double click on the
sample and then just turn the volume
down here but it is changing the volume
here just so you know so let's turn down
the volume
okay all right so I just changed the
volume in the sample editor so we're
going to go over the sample editor a
little bit later uh but this is
something uh interesting which I kind of
want to go over with you guys soon okay
so I like this pattern what's going on
here so I'm going to control left click
the stairs shift uh shift and left click
and that's going to copy them shift left
click again and I'm just duplicating
this pattern bigger and bigger and
bigger so now we have it like this
[Music]
perfect and I'm just going to add a
snare here and it's just going to kind
of make it a little bit more intense and
then we're gonna
kind of double up the snares here so
it's going to go like
[Music]
[Music]
okay cool and then I'm going to take all
these patterns by selecting them and
then I'm going to right click and just
drag them a little bit shorter so that
it ends kind of like this
foreign
[Music]
so we got something like that and so we
have some sort of build up for like some
type of EDM drop this is hilarious I
don't know what I'm making right now
um so
um I think that this is also important
if you work on a lot of different genres
you're going to improve greatly so if
you just stick in one genre
um your music May kind of get stifled I
find myself uh the times I improve the
most is when I completely switch what
I'm making and I make something
completely different and then
I learned a lot from uh that experience
so uh also spending time spent time with
people that don't make the same music as
you do if you find producers online and
just hang out with them and collaborate
and make all kinds of different music
with different people you'll improve so
much I can promise you that so I'm just
going to shift clip Up Arrow uh and move
that to the track above so that we have
our snares together here sweet and now I
think that we're ready uh and by the way
again this is just trial there I was
just clicking these I just zoomed in
here and just click these snares until
it sounded good so uh you guys can as I
said if you need to copy what I'm doing
just uh keep along with the project
that's completely fine
um but yeah I encourage you guys to mess
around okay even if it doesn't sound
good it's still better I would say it's
better you're in a better spot if your
song sounds like 10 times worse than
mine if you're doing something that
you're doing rather than you have
something that sounds identical to mine
because that means that you're probably
not learning very much and I I can
understand the wants and need to when
you're learning something new to follow
everything exactly but if you can take a
little a little jump out here and there
and get out of your comfort zone and do
something that I'm not doing
it'll really help you learn from your
mistakes and also figure out things that
you didn't know before so I'm just going
to keep pushing that like the entire
course and stuff wish you the guys to do
stuff on your own uh because I I know I
remember when I was in college we'd have
people uh that would just follow it
literally everything down to the wire
and they never improved ever and it was
really sad to see because like the
people who messed up and got actually
failing grades in the beginning of the
course they were the people who wanted
to try out different stuff and then they
would end up coming back and being way
better and were able to do anything that
they needed uh so that's that's
something interesting that I kind of
learned at college and I think it
definitely applies to music production
as well okay enough talking let's just
make an egm drop here so what am I going
to do here I'm going to copy these
chords so I'm gonna double click on this
uh this pattern and I'm just gonna get
rid of this red line at the top there
I'm going to control C control I'm not
going to control V I'm just gonna copy
this I want the chords so I'm going to
copy them
uh for now
um and what do we do here why don't we
add a new pattern so I'm going to click
the plus icon and I'm going to name this
EDM chords
cool and we're gonna click this right
here and just stretch it and then this
is where I want my EDM chords to play
all right now let's add a synthesizer so
let's go to flex and I guess we're just
gonna use flex for everything because
it's it's such a good plug-in that it
really works for everything uh well we
can mess around with some other actually
you know what let's not use flex that
would be the easy way out let's use
let's use a different instrument let's
mess around let's use
uh what can we use here that you guys
have
um
let's see
I the thing is I actually don't remember
I know Flex is for sure in the free
version of FL Studio but I don't
remember if some of these other ones are
um I forgot okay
you guys will have to see you uh so
there's a bunch of other so you see how
the category says Cynthia you can click
on these so like we could use GMS this
plugin this looks really weird but we
could use this plugin to make uh some
chords but I'm not sure if you guys have
this in the free version NFL so yeah
okay just to play it safe actually I am
going to use flex just because I know
for a fact that you guys have this
plugin so okay so what am I going to do
here let's go to arcsun cityscape and
just click on the first thing here I
think this one sounds pretty good so
let's uh now what I'm gonna do
um if you uh okay so I'm just gonna make
sure I'm selected on this pattern our
EDM chords I'm gonna go to our Channel
rack and then I'm going to c70s bounce
where uh our pattern uh where I want to
put my chords in I'm going to right
click go to piano roll here we go copy
and paste and now we have this uh let's
just listen to the pattern
interesting Okay cool so this is what we
have right now
okay that's super lame um okay let's see
if there's other instruments because
that one's really yeah it's not very not
very fantastic
[Music]
hmm
Smith's around here
[Music]
okay interesting now you guys don't know
uh aren't gonna know why I'm telling you
to click these off but just click uh the
power button on this the power button on
this and then I'm going to mess around
with these knobs and I'm going to see
how I can change the sound to sounds uh
to something cooler now I feel like this
is a little bit cheating because I
already know what all of these do and
you guys have absolutely no idea what
any of them do so I give you permission
to copy what I'm doing here if you want
to get the same sounding sound that I
have
um however
I'm going to try to quickly explain what
these do but I'm not going to spend too
much time on it because this is going to
be part of a different course which is
going to go more in depth into sound
design and I don't want to overload you
guys with designing your own sounds uh
in the beginner course because that's
just like really difficult and it takes
a lot of trial and error okay so filter
so volume envelopes and filter envelopes
you can think of this as
um
and I haven't taught you guys automation
yet so you guys I can't even use that as
an example yeah this is a big problem
okay well mess around with these until
you get a sound that you like uh I know
what these do so I'm gonna just get it
the way I want it to sound
foreign
[Music]
what it sounds like so I'm going to just
change change it to the way I want it
okay perfect I like that what is the
symbol
perfect okay I like that all right now
we're gonna mess around with some stuff
so there's this cool thing called Chop
uh if we go to this wrench right here
and click chop
[Music]
okay why don't we go to this drop down
arrow and we can click different presets
here and we can try out different
chopping methods that one sounds really
bad
[Music]
thank you
see some I'm just gonna see if there's
any that sound decent here
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
hmm I don't like the way any of these
sounds so I'm actually going to make my
own so remember how I said the one and
the three and the two and the four uh
how that certain pattern so we're gonna
copy that so I'm gonna control C control
R and no wait my bad sorry not control C
control shift left click select all
these select all these and then I'm
gonna show you guys uh some really neat
quick shortcuts so I'm going to drag all
these shorts and it's gonna let me drag
all of them at the same time
I'm gonna make it 1 8 of a bar long and
then I'm going to shift left click and
it will copy everything so I can make my
own
foreign
[Music]
thing here I'm going to copy these notes
like so and then I'm going to do this
it's going to go to do
[Music]
okay and as you this is a perfect time
to
this is a perfect time to show you guys
uh what the a b a b or a b a c thing I
was talking about because you can see
how the rhythm is the same with one and
three and how the rhythm is the same
with two and four so this is a great
example of how you can build patterns
that your listeners can listen to and
not get distracted by what's going on so
I use a lot shortcuts to make this
really quickly and you know how long it
would be how painfully long it would be
if I sat here and clicked each one of
these individually and there's no way
I'm going to do that so we're going to
be using shortcuts that way I can teach
you guys the right way to be using FL to
be more efficient and not teaching you
guys how to click in each one of these
because that just takes so long
okay so now we have something a lot more
interesting
okay here's what we need we need to
right click select all this
um and then I'm going to duplicate
I'm going to duplicate this I'm going to
clone it
and then I'm going to copy and paste
these chords into the second instance of
this instrument and then I'm going to
change the instrument
[Music]
oh that sounds cool okay hold on so I'm
going to do the exact same things before
but I am going to mute the instrument so
I'm going to go to my channel rack and
I'm just going to click on this
and now we're only listening to the new
clone instrument that we added in
because remember illumi alumin Sun
however you say that that was the first
instrument that we're making the pattern
with I just clicked on this little Green
Dot muted it now we have this one and
let's just make this the way I said
before I take off delay take off Reverb
by clicking the power buttons move this
down drag
[Music]
okay I'm going to enable this back
all right we're gonna clone it again
now now we're flying we are flying mach
10 speed right here okay so let's copy
and paste it here again we're going to
mute both of these and then we're going
to listen to this one and we're going to
find another cool something
that actually sounds really cool okay
what does this sound like all together
foreign
[Music]
cool I actually want this to be like an
octave up so like what if I took this
made it an octave up like this
perfect okay and then I'm just going to
turn this volume way down like this
[Music]
perfect okay and then I'm going to make
a base so what we're gonna do
is we're going to go to any of these
patterns just click it go to the bottom
here we're going to copy all these notes
by Ctrl shift left click copy all the
notes
okay I don't know what's being weird
there I just yeah okay Ctrl C
then we're gonna go to our Channel rack
we're gonna go to the plus icon we're
gonna go to flex
Archangel cityscape I'm gonna just click
one of these presets right here I'm
gonna go to my playlist I'm gonna click
the plus icon I'm gonna name it base
uh then I'm gonna put it right here
lengthen it
Channel rack right click piano roll on
the base Ctrl V
and now we have this
[Music]
Okay now what's super cool with bass
lines if you have this like little
octave thing going up so like what I
want to do is I want to take every like
second note here and then this middle
Mount and I'm just going to control
shift left click all these notes I'm
going to do control up arrow and this is
something I kind of do in a lot of my
more like dance songs is I'll do this
and it sounds like this
[Music]
and obviously I'm using all stock
plugins and I'm using just presets so
like this is like very beginner producer
stuff like obviously my more advanced
courses I'm going to show you guys how
to sound design all your own songs the
art sounds all your own uh samples
everything we're gonna go through all
that uh so if you're somebody who's
already used FL and for some reason
you're watching a beginner course yes I
know all this stuff is insanely easy and
what I'm doing is I'm just trying to get
somebody who's never used music
production before to get a grasp on how
they can begin making music even if it's
with presets and samples and loops and
all kinds of stuff because what's
important is that you have a grasp of
how to make
what's important is that you have a
grasp on how to make songs before you
start going to nitty-gritty details so
with this I made this Baseline and we're
going to do the same thing we're going
to go click on this Baseline right here
that way it's selected we're going to
clone the base we're going to make a
second base instrument I'm going to
control C I'm going to control V and
then we're going to mute the first this
one with the pattern and we're going to
find
Okay so
I'm also going to mute the chords up
here
all right let's find something
perfect let's listen to this together
that sounds really good okay I'm just
gonna leave it like that honestly
um I don't need to change anything let's
just do it
[Music]
okay the only thing missing is that I
need a Melody so I'm going to control
shifts uh and then shift down arrow and
then we're gonna make a lead on top of
here so
all right I'm gonna double click the
tuba staccato whoops it's not too bad
anymore it's actually a chill guitar so
that's a little confusing but I'm gonna
control C just copy this melody go back
to my playlist I'm gonna hit the plus
icon up here pattern I'm gonna name it
Melody
and obviously I'm going faster just
because these are all things that we've
gone over okay
scroll this lengthen it out
Generac
add a new flex plugin
actually yeah we're gonna do Flex again
anyways all right let's add in another
flex and let's right click on Flex go to
piano roll and we're in the melody
pattern uh let's click Ctrl V it's going
to paste our melody in here uh and then
I'm going to just right click so I'm
only listening to this
[Music]
okay let's just try different stuff
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
okay so I have something that sounds
interesting so let's listen to it all
together
[Music]
okay cool uh let's control shift copy
all this shifts uh actually I'm gonna so
once I select all these and I have this
little red thing above here I can hit
Ctrl B with all these selected and I'll
just duplicate it again
all right now we're going to do
something really interesting which I
haven't showed you guys yet so we are
going to click on this melody and we're
going to click make unique and what
that's going to do is it's going to put
a number two on this melody and that
means that we can actually change this
melody to whatever we want and it won't
affect the first version
[Music]
so now we have this look at so it goes
[Music]
and that okay I'm not gonna try to sing
the melody but
[Music]
I don't know whatever I mean I'm not
really a huge fan of this EDM Port
anyways but
I think it needs drums because it's
lacking it's lacking right here so I
think we need to go do like a four on
the floor beat kind of have like a
little kick snare thing going on so
let's go to kicks
we're just gonna add a kick on every
single one of these lines just boom boom
boom boom so now it's gonna go like this
okay we're gonna double click on this uh
kick and I'm just gonna click on this
out and I'm just going to make it lower
[Music]
and my click normalize uh I don't really
I'm not gonna go through why I'm doing
this but it's going to make it sound
better
[Music]
this is interesting
um okay it's really funny like going
backwards because now I'm using like all
like completely basic tools and so like
I'm trying to make something that's like
doesn't sound completely terrible with
like really basic stuff so I'm just
gonna control shift left click shift
left click again uh copy all this over
and now we have this
[Music]
okay this this base is like way too loud
so let's fix that so let's scroll down a
little bit it's black sting it
[Music]
okay I'm gonna add in a snare
[Music]
okay let's just add in some hi-hats so
so we're gonna zoom in here
excuse me we're gonna put a zoom uh
we're gonna zoom in here we're gonna put
a hi-hat on every other side here
[Music]
oh it's kind of sounding cool let's do
it like a little double right there
[Music]
oh that's kind of that's kind of that's
a Bop right there
Bop hi-hat Melody let's go
oh whoops accidentally that's funny I
put it one too close okay
oh I see what I did okay whoops see so I
just moved that a little off so I just
gotta fix it all right there we go I
think it's better now
[Music]
okay yep sure that's the EDM part okay
cool
all right we're making progress so what
do we got so far let's listen to the
whole thing because so far I have no
idea what I'm making
[Music]
this is so funny
[Music]
thank you
okay this is very interesting
um yes very very interesting song so now
we're gonna make a hip-hop part because
you guys need to learn how to make all
kinds of different genres so
what should we do for the hip-hop part I
kind of like this thing going on here I
feel like this could actually turn into
something cool
okay so why don't we double click this
uh Ctrl C copy that we're gonna go back
here
just kind of unmute everything by right
clicking this uh green box we're going
to click the pattern icon we're going to
go into hip hop parts
I can't spell Parts there we go okay
cool we're gonna put this pattern
uh okay so this is interesting so we
needed to kind of
uh transition out of this Emmy part so
let's just Ctrl C and copy all the base
stuff and just paste it here so have
something like
okay I'm trying to figure out how to
like get out of this part so maybe I can
just kind of delete all the stuff and it
just kind of goes like
[Music]
and it just kind of ends with this last
note
yeah something like that and then we can
go into some type of loop do we have
loops in the drum packs I actually have
no idea oh we do no way okay so yeah
click on loops
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
these are very interesting
um okay so I haven't really explained
Loops so samples obviously they're just
one sample and a loop is just a bunch of
samples uh put into a loop which you can
use and pretty simple so if I drag this
in here
this is going to be a very interesting
transition so we're going from this
[Music]
okay so if if like let's say I drag in
that Loop and I don't like it I can
actually drag a loop on top of that Loop
and it will replace it
[Music]
I mean that's not typically the type of
hip-hop drums I would choose but you
know what well let's just roll with it
because why not okay so what we have
here we need to add in a hip-hop
instrument that's going to sound uh
let's just pick something incredibly
cliche Let's uh get a flute so we're
gonna add in another Flex
um we're gonna go to wind instruments
we're going to go to flutes let's do
flute staccato and let's just right
click on the flute actually let's make
sure we're in our patterns let's click
on the hip-hop part let's right click
our flute staccato go to piano roll copy
and paste this in here and now we have
this let's go to pattern
[Music]
okay so I need a control C control V
that up because the notes are too low
it's not playing
[Music]
okay that's actually kind of cool um
okay so we're going to take this hip-hop
art we're gonna place it up above here
and now we have this
foreign
okay this is very interesting
um now we need to have a 808 that just
like goes sounds really sick so let's uh
what should we do here uh why don't we
copy the lower notes on this Arc just
like so Ctrl C them and we're gonna go
to channelrack again
and finally we're going to go to flex
who would have guessed it uh now let's
go to a mobile tuned 808 base and let's
just click on like one of these so let's
see
oh that's clean
I'm just going to turn the compress up
instead of just make it louder this
doesn't sound bad okay cool
now we're going to go to the flute
staccato and I'm just going to go to our
base instrument so you can see we've
added so many instruments so far so
let's just control V
[Music]
Okay cool so I'm going to turn down the
basic just slightly
and we're gonna try to make like
I don't exactly know what kind of
I don't make a ton of hip-hop so this is
gonna be really interesting uh probably
get roast in the comments for making the
like crappiest hip-hop beat of all time
using stock plugins
[Music]
what if it was like this and just kind
of like
I don't know something like this
[Music]
hmm
what if it was like something like that
[Music]
okay something like this maybe I have no
idea
I have no idea we might make our own
drums because I really don't like that
drum sample I'm not gonna lie it sounds
really trash
um okay let's just put more of this
stuff here
right now I'm just doing basically
everything
again that uh went over before just kind
of filling it in as I see fit so we're
just adding it Baseline I'm pretty much
doing the same process I did with the
EDM I'm just changing the instruments to
fit the genre and I'm just
trying to make the bass line sound like
it fits more with a hip-hop song so I
already have listened to tons of hip-hop
I've listened to tons of like all
different kinds of genres so I already
kind of know okay I feel like this space
line is going to be more like this in
this genre and more like this in this
genre so I'm just kind of changing the
Baseline based on what I think would
sound good so
that's the thought process there
uh you know what sound really cool is if
we had like a little note here and then
it went like really high pitched like
this
[Music]
okay we're just going to repeat this
part because I don't want to keep
listening to the EDM part uh and then
we're going to see if there's any
foreign
[Music]
that's not hip-hop that's literally just
not at all
okay I guess we're sticking with this
um that's fine
um let's see is there anything else I
can add to make this more interesting I
could go to channelrack
and you know what okay we're actually
going to I'm without going to Generac
I'm going to stop adding new instruments
because we have a bunch uh let's click
on hip-hop part we're going to split
this like I did before we're going to
take the
uh we're gonna take the bass boosted and
we're gonna just put this lower
and we're gonna have our Melody here
um the last thing I want to do is I want
to add in some like
uh you guys will see what I'm about to
do so I'm going to copy the bass notes
right here I'm going to hit Ctrl C we're
going to navigate to the brass
instrument
right here and do this
[Music]
foreign
I am going to add another instrument I'm
going to add in another flex and it's
going to be a brass but I want to be
staccato I don't want it to be a lengthy
so we're going to go to full brass
staccato
and from there I'm going to go back
navigate back here
I'm just going to navigate to the
instrument I just added and paste that
[Music]
okay and then I need it to kind of like
foreign
[Music]
okay and again I'm just changing the
volume to make sure it fits we're going
to go back here we're going to split the
pattern once more and then we have the
base Parts oh whoops I'm going to drag
this up like so I'm going to delete this
and then I'm just going to copy this
over here
okay so we made hip hop EDM and
orchestral music all in one pattern and
all in one take uh that's very
interesting I don't think I've ever done
this before
and the best part is it all sounds like
well
let's just put it this way it is not my
best work that I've ever made but you
know what uh I think a little bit of
forgiveness is going to be accepted
since I'm using all stock presets and
plugins since that's what I'm working
with uh okay guys hopefully uh we can go
to the next chapter confident and you
have at least something so
even if you don't have all this that's
fine in fact even if you just made one
of these sections like let's say you
just worked on the hour Castro or you
just did the the EDM part where you just
did the hip-hop part that's fine I'm
just kind of going over a broad range
and actually I don't even expect you
guys to be able to completely following
everything I've done if you have if this
is your first time using FL Studio and
you have everything I have up to this
point and did your own take on it that
is insane like that is I'm so like proud
that you did that if you haven't gotten
to that point I do not blame you at all
I was going extremely fast uh and the
amount of times that you're probably
gonna have to go back and forth to see
how I did things over again I know it's
probably gonna be tough so if you can't
make everything the way I did it or get
it to sound this good that's completely
fine don't worry okay it's gonna be okay
so
um I think what we I think we're pretty
much ready to go to the next part of the
uh tutorial so with that why don't we go
to the next chapter
okay this chapter is gonna be fun first
we are going to go to our Channel rack
and we are going to click all and we are
going to see all of these instruments
that we added and what we're going to do
is you're going to hold shift go to
start from the very first instrument
shift left click and drag your mouse
down and it will automatically select
all of these then you can scroll down a
little bit hold shift again
click these last few
now click control
hell
and what it's going to do okay you're
not going to know what this is going to
do at first I'm just gonna explain what
it did so click X on your channel rack
now it's going to pop open this menu
right here you're just gonna click
windowed on this so now we have this
this is called our mixer and what it did
right now is it just placed every single
one of our instruments on a mixer track
and named it and colored it for us is
super convenient so again that is Ctrl L
okay so we're gonna keep this mixer open
and we're going to go to the beginning
of the song again and click play and
just see what it's doing
foreign
[Music]
okay I'm gonna make one last change to
this because I just thought of it
it's gonna go
[Music]
okay so it's gonna be like this
no no it needs to go
okay
[Music]
something like that okay I know I said
that we were doing mixing let's go back
to the mixer sorry I just had to make
that change because I realized that it
would sound cool okay so
as you saw the mixer uh what or the
mixer this is uh what's called the mixer
so we have the channel rack right here
we have the piano roll right here we
have the channel rack oh wait my bad
hold on let's try that again playlist is
here
this is the playlist
this is the piano roll this is the
channel rack and then this is the mixer
okay and what the mixer does is it
essentially let's just close out the
rest of this I just want to see my mixer
so what the mixer does is it lets us
control the volume and effects of
individual instruments so that we can
kind of blend them together okay
so the first thing to put uh to know is
that this changes the volume oh my
goodness okay let's go to the beginning
of the song just to try mixing this part
of the song
so I'm going to right click select and
we're just going to focus on this little
area we're going to go here and
so you can see this changes the volume
here so this is going to be uh where
we're going to be leveling a lot I also
use the volume a lot here so uh let's
right click and just reset all these
because I like the way the volume was
initially
and if I right click it's going to sell
out here
and note this is not the same as
actually soloing here so if you do have
to so if I right click in Solo an
instrument that is muted in my mixer
it's going to play nothing because
you see so if I these are separate
basically is what I'm trying to get at
so
uh why don't we focus on just
adding some effects to some of these
instruments so
I think some Reverb would sound really
cool on this electric piano so why don't
we go to this slot uh there's slot one
through ten just click slot one and
let's find fruity Reverb too
and click this here so now we have this
Reverb plug-in and this is going to make
it sound like it's in a room essentially
so it's just up the wetness
[Music]
okay and then if you middle Mouse scroll
you can actually move these effects
around here and so that might be helpful
for you so let's move the Reverb here
and in the first lot why don't we do
fruity delayed ink and just click on
that and this is just to add another
effect here and you don't need to know
what any of this does you can just
listen to how it sounds
and if you don't want to hear an effect
at any time you can just simply mute it
up here
I think that sounds great so now we're
going to go to Strings slow and
um to make some quick changes here I'm
gonna go to slot one and I'm going to
add fruity parametric eq2 and what
that's going to do is it's going to
allow me to change the frequencies of
this particular instrument this is what
you're going to be using probably all
the time okay this is what's referred to
as mixing so let's say I have two parts
of my song that sound like they're
conflicting with each other so we have
we have some low end here but if you
remember we also have my bass instrument
here
um if we listen to the bass here we have
this going on here
oh wait hold on I have to
so you see we have two things that have
low end so they're going to be fighting
for space in the mix essentially what
that means is imagine you're like
packing a
um I forgot what the trucks are called
that when you move like a house and you
have to put all this a moving van yeah
I'm moving in okay so when you have a
moving bin you have to fit all the items
in your house into the moving bed and
there's a very unefficient way of doing
that which would be to put all the
things and try to stuff them in the back
but rather what you'd want to do is kind
of figure out where everything could you
might put the heavier stuff in the back
maybe or you would want to space it out
properly so that everything has its spot
and everything has its place in the
moving band in the same way with your
mix every every single instrument wants
to have a space in that mix and you
don't want to have it overcrowded in
certain areas so if you have too many
base instruments it's going to sound
overcrowded and it's going to sound not
even it's not going to sound Pleasant to
the ear because you'll have too many
things going on in the bass instruments
um A good rule of thumb to remember is
that you can have more things happening
the higher up you go so what do I mean
by that if you have a like well let's
just listen to our Melody so we have
this chill guitar
sounds higher pitched than this
that's a lot lower into this I'd say
that's even maybe even lower than this
or maybe this is lower I'm not sure
point being I can have less bass
instruments going at the same time then
I can have going with a melody
I could have a lot of that's why I have
three uh like three different kinds of
pianos and strings instruments but I
can't have three different kinds of
basses because all the bases would be
fighting for space so what we're going
to do is we're going to unclick on
everything here we're going to select
everything here and what we're going to
do is I'm just going to work on just
mixing in the strings with the rest of
the song so I'm going to open up by
double clicking the parametric eq2 and
make sure that you are selected on the
correct instrument so I have all strings
slow and we're going to just move uh
we're going to cut out some frequencies
to make it fit better
so you see what this does
so I'm just left clicking and moving
these around so I'm going to take out
the low end out of the strings
[Music]
so I'm just I'm trying to move it I want
to get it to sound good and fit well in
the mix so I'm not really there's uh
just do what sounds good so like change
these until you think it sounds nice and
then turn it off and on to see if it
sounded better
okay I think it sounds a little bit
better I think it sounds a little bit
more tighter uh and a little bit better
in the mix now I'm going to add another
EQ onto my electric piano right here
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so maybe I want to take the base out of
one of these bases completely
[Music]
thank you
foreign
I'm just adding eqs on every one of
these instruments and just trying to get
it to sound like it fits together by
just taming some of the frequencies I
think are overlapping on each other
[Music]
Okay cool so uh right here basically
what we're doing is again we're just
adding different instruments and I think
that maybe a Reverb would sound
interesting here so why don't we add a
Reverb also on the guitar
oops
you guys actually don't have that
plug-in I forgot I like instinctively
opened my own Reverb plugin that I have
but you guys don't have this so we're
gonna open up pretty Reverb to you my
bad
and then I just want to put hover over
[Music]
Okay cool so
got something going on here I think that
it sounds a lot better
um cool so if you ever want to disable
the effects entirely you can just go
down down here and click on this little
icon
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Okay cool so this just we're just adding
effects here and we're just uh trying to
make everything fit together uh why
don't we go to the this is gonna need a
lot more mixing I think is this EDM part
right here
yeah it doesn't not there's a lot of
stuff that doesn't work here so why
don't we fix it so let's focus on
[Music]
okay and a quick way to take out low end
is we have it actually in EQ here I can
actually go in and just really quickly
just make really quick adjustments here
just by moving stuff around and I can
make really fast adjustments here so uh
why don't we do that for a few things
here
[Music]
and like that I was just able to EQ
these things really quickly in a really
convenient way to try to make it sound
better and so now we can add in the bass
by unmuting these right here
[Music]
get it to fit together and let's listen
[Music]
all right I'm gonna add a Reverb to the
lead I think it would sound cool
[Music]
and then this also needs a Reverb this
little illumi Sun thing I'm just gonna
add one to there
[Music]
sounds good to me okay cool uh and then
so finally we're just gonna mix the
hip-hop part so let's select
okay you already know the flute needs
some reboot let's add Reverb to
everything uh okay Reverb actually does
drown out a lot of stuff so if you want
something more present in the center of
your mix uh basically what it would uh
to explain to somebody who's never
understood that before it'd be like
something can sound far away from you
and something can sound really close to
you and the items that you want close to
you are usually going to be your lower
end instruments so your base your drums
um also I I find that vocals fit really
nicely when they're in the center
um if if you have vocals that sound like
they're far away uh it can sound
I don't know how to put it it just
doesn't sound right if you listen to a
lot of music you'll have there's there's
some artists that can get away with
doing some really crazy stuff I know uh
Billy eilish has a song where uh her
brother produces it and he actually
throws the vocals really wide and far
away which is very unique uh you don't
hear very many artists do that so that
was really interesting but that's like
an example which goes against the norms
so sometimes you can get away with doing
stuff with that but generally you want
your vocal your drums your bass all in
the center and then you can work from
there to uh try to uh make some things
far away so it depends what do you want
far away in your song what do you want
close and so I'm gonna add a little
Reaper on this flute because I think it
would sound interesting
[Music]
and again I just clicked the flute here
and it's going to show me the effects
for the specific flute and then I can
add the effects here so I know I didn't
really explain that super well so like
when you click on this and it highlights
in green that's going to be the one
that's selected and I can add an EQ here
I can also EQ it here uh neither of them
matter and if you need to reset these
you just right click on the on these
little knobs and click res and right
click and click reset and we'll reset
them for you okay so I'm just in it uh
oh yeah this is something I didn't
explain either in my bed if you scroll
the uh the way I'm navigating this mixer
is by scroll scroll Wheeling on the
mixer so you just scroll wheel in the
middle here and it will scroll between
these and then you have different uh
settings here I use wide but you can use
wide three you can use wide all all
these different things are going to show
you different ways that you can organize
your mixer
so right here
[Music]
I mean you're only going to be able to
mix so much in the beginning stages as a
as a producer and you'll find more uses
for mixing as uh you develop your uh
your skills and you're producing more
stuff you'll find that you need to do
more so
I think from here what we're going to do
is move on to Automation and this part
I'm really excited for so let's move on
to the next chapter
okay this is an excellent point in the
tutorial to show you what just happened
so my file completely just crashed and I
need to pull up a backup and I lost all
the uh recording for one of the
tutorials so what we're going to do is
I'm going to show you guys what happens
when what to do when your project just
crashes now you're going to go to backup
and you can see here
um I can just right click on this top
one and click open and it's going to
open back up all the changes that we
made so I'm just going to click no and I
have the backups enabled so I forgot to
uh actually go over this with you guys
and since I ran into a crash I think it
is uh helpful to just show you guys what
to do to mitigate crashes happening and
uh if they do happen what you can do to
fix it so we're going to go to options
here and I'm just going to help you guys
get this set up so instead of pop-up all
this stuff just hit F12 close it all out
we're gonna hit playlist and we're back
to where we were uh and I'm gonna go
over everything that I kind of went over
before and I'm just going to show you
guys how I did that and we're going to
go over it again with this file so uh
we're gonna go up to options
uh we're gonna go to general settings
I believe uh let's see
maybe it's project
maybe it's not project file
okay yeah uh backup so you see how it
says auto save frequently every five
minutes before risky operations that's
what I do and maximum 100 so that's
that's what I what I do and what that
does is it just saves like literally
every five minutes automatically so that
it doesn't like I never have something
I never miss anything so right here I
was uh basically what I was showing you
guys is how to create automations and
what automations do uh in the project is
they are going to uh change the the mix
volume of an effect so as I said before
right here you have the mix amount so
this is going to control how much of a
certain effect you want in the project
so if I have this at half it's going to
be 50 of this effect 0 that's zero
percent of the effect so with the Reverb
that I was showing you guys before this
is 100 it's on zero percent it's off and
then incrementally increasing it so
let's say I want it to increase over
time how would I do that how would I
want in my song I want the Reverb to
gradually go in because right now I've
only shown you guys how to have it on or
either off so to gradually have it in
and this is where you need a automation
so to do this you would right click uh I
I like to have my mix all the way down
my automations and I'll show you why in
a second and then you just right click
this and click create automation clip
and what that's going to do is when you
click that it's going to create a blank
automation clip on whatever uh whatever
effect you had so you see I created two
automation Clips right here which called
Reverb and delay and when I created
these I had them at zero and then I
right clicked it and clicked create
automation clip once you do that you can
just right click and it places a little
Point here and you can right click the
points and delete them if you need and
yours will probably look something like
this it'll look like all the way flat uh
what I did was I just created a point
and then I moved it so that it gradually
turns on from bar one to Bar five it's
going to gradually go up and that was my
plan and then over here I just
the thing I did was I created another
Point here
and I just drag that to the top right
corner and then I did that for both of
these uh and then so I have the delay
and the Reverb gradually going up
the next thing that I talked about
before it crashed and this is what
caused it to crash is I said you know
what would be so cool is if you could
have the instrument change the actual
instrument sound change as you uh as you
as the song goes on and so that's
exactly what I did I had the chords here
and I had these two
um and uh these two automations and what
these automations do is essentially they
change the length of the the way it
plays so if we listen to this
let me make sure I have all these
enabled
I'm not sure where it's muted but hold
on let's see
why is it muted
what what is going on
okay one second I'm gonna try to figure
out why this isn't playing
[Music]
oh that's why it's not playing I don't
have my volume turned on
there we go I had my entire computer
muted all right and now we should be
able to hear it
so you can see when I turn on this
automation it gets way longer the actual
notes and so how I did that was is I
double clicked illumi Sun
and then you can actually create the
automations by right clicking sustain is
what makes
uh this is the this is what I created
the automation with I I had it at zero
before and I right clicked it and I
clicked create automation clip and you
can do this on any knob in the entire
the entire program you can right click
and create automation
you could create an automation okay
never mind you can't create an
automation for that but you can create
an automation with almost every single
thing in this program so just try right
clicking things and seeing what you can
make automations with it's really fun so
I created two automation Clips with this
and you might be wondering okay how did
you get the automation Clips to not be
the entire length of the song like this
bottom one the way you do that is by
right clicking the the duration uh that
you want to repeat and then when you
create an automation it'll create it
within this this like red bar remember
you right click and hover over that and
that's how I do that
um I feel a little bit bad that I didn't
have the initial file I had to kind of
go over it like this since it crashed
but we're just going to kind of work
with it so
um I'm gonna make one more automation
from the ground up just so that you guys
aren't completely out of the blue since
I made these before and you didn't
really see how I made them so I'll make
one from scratcher so why don't we go to
what I uh okay what can I do here
um we'll have the strings not be in the
first four bars we'll have them
gradually come in with volume so
that sounds super weird oh I yeah I
turned on this effect here I'm gonna
delete that okay
okay let's right click this uh knob
right here and click create automation
clip
and right here remember I selected this
so it's going to give me strings volume
so I'm gonna drag this down and we don't
hear the strings obviously because
that's the volume of the strings and if
I make this just windowed and we can
just watch what this what this does as
it
perfect and then you can see what
happens and for the rest of the song
it's going to be at the max volume
cool cool okay and so as I said before
you can right click and place extra
things to manipulate uh what's going on
here I'm going to just delete this point
and this point in this point I still put
a bunch of points uh and if this little
middle note if you left click it and
drag up and down you can actually change
the way it like it if it goes gradual or
not gradual it's really cool and then if
you right click on the endnote here it
gives you our either of these notes it
gives you tons of options for different
uh ways you can have it progress so this
is really fun to just mess around with I
encourage you guys to just experiment
but like you have like stairs here so I
could click at these and it like
there's so many like you have no idea
like there are so many different things
that you can do half sign like
I don't know what that does but yeah uh
single curve is the default one
so this is the one I almost always use
uh unless I'm trying to do something
fancy but yeah so that's how you make
automations so I'm just gonna control
this and just put it lower I like most
my automation Clips down here away out
of the way of my other stuff so let's
just kind of keep these on their own
little thing going on down here
um and yeah so that's that's essentially
how automations work it's just going to
uh gradually change any effects or Knob
in the entire program whether that's in
an instrument an effect a volume over
time and you can even do that to
painting you can do that for these
panning knobs right here
um so make sure you click on all and as
you can see there that's where the
automations are so we have Automation
and we have our automation stored in our
Channel rack as well uh you don't really
need to worry about that too much uh
you're not going to use the chainrack
automations for a whole lot of things so
if we click all you can I can even right
click these and I can create animations
I think you guys get the point you can
pretty much create automations for every
single knob in the thing and the only
thing that's uh stopping you is your
creativity to use automations and so uh
yeah we didn't really need to go too in
depth on this I just wanted to show you
that this is a possibility of something
that you could work with if you'd like
uh and the rest is up to you what you
want to do with it so I created a few
simple ones here you don't have to add
these if you don't want to but uh we're
gonna move on to the final part the
final chapter of the beginner course and
yeah so let's move on
all right we made it to the end finally
we are going to master the track so what
is mastering mastering is essentially
making the entire song Sound cohesive
and together for the final product that
you're going to deliver so the way that
we do this is we are going to go to our
master
it's has M right here in its master and
what this does is every single one of
these uh uh you can see that there's
little arrows oh I forgot to mention
this okay so in the mixer you have each
one of these instruments right
now these instruments you have this
little arrow and so if I take this Arrow
off it's not going to play but if I
click it into this you can see there's a
little wire going into it it's going
into the master so every single one of
these instruments its wire is going to
the master now uh this is called routing
so this is going to be an advanced topic
that we're not going to go over in this
course but in the advanced course we're
going to go into how routing can allow
you to make buses and control multiple
instruments volume and effects all at
the same time that's a really Advanced
topic and I'm not going to show you guys
how to do that now but that that you
basically if you can understand that
each one of these has like a wire and
that you can use this wire and that uh
to direct it that that's a possibility
that's all you need to know right now
and what you need to know is that by
default all of the wires are connected
to the master and the master is where
all the volume goes into so I turn this
off I hear nothing okay but you can see
all of these are going into here
okay so what are we going to put on the
master the first thing we're going to
put on the master is we're going to go
to slot 10 and we're just going to put a
fruity
uh we're gonna put Maximus okay and what
Maximus is going to do is it's just
going to keep it from going over zero
uh so when it things go above zero it's
called clipping and clipping uh does not
sound very good it can sound distorted
it can sound uh poor quality it just
doesn't sound good so you don't have
your songs going above zero when you're
starting off uh it's really gonna hurt
people's ears so make sure
um you put Maximus at the end just to
make sure as a beginner that your songs
are not blaring out people's faces
um and then
there's a few things that we can do to
kind of
make it sound a little bit more
interesting so I think that what we
could do is we could add a fruity
multi-band compressor uh and I know if
that's like you're like I don't know
what this is
um that's okay we can go into this into
a the more advanced course as well but
maybe you could just try one of these
presets here so you could just do a
mastering 2.4 DB maybe and just put that
on there and see if it sounds better
foreign
[Music]
for mastering for a beginner project
basically I just don't want to peeking
above zero that is the mastering that
you guys will be focusing on and then if
you if you'd like you can add an EQ and
then make sure to click uh this Lin what
that essentially this is basically just
Mastery mode it's called linear phase
you want that enabled when you are using
EQ okay uh I'm we're not going to
elaborate past that point but so
essentially if you want to make brief
changes to your master you're affecting
everything at the same time so make a
very minute changes if if it's something
that you can fix in the mix like let's
say you think that this these chords in
the mix need less low end do not change
that in the master change that in the
mix the master is just supposed to
accentuate everything together so
I'm Mike Buster Heine just very slightly
here right
foreign
[Music]
basic changes like this you're not going
to do very big large things on the
master just very basic things to make it
sound a little bit overall more cohesive
um so yeah so you can add in whoops you
can add in a uh maybe a little EQ you
can add in a little multiband compressor
maybe a Maximus uh and then the Maximus
has all kinds of different uh presets
that you can use and these are going to
be okay for when you're beginning music
obviously I'm not going to use these
myself because I I have my own mastering
process over the I have my own plugins
and all kinds of things that I use for
mastering but this will be good if
you're making just a very basic song uh
it could probably make it sound louder
and more clear
okay that sounds pretty bad so we're not
going to use that but uh if you ever
want to um use a different preset you
can just click on default to go back to
the initial one
um experiment like just try different
stuff add different things see what it
sounds like
um and just find something but at very
least have a limiter at the end so
Maximus or fruity limiter put that at
the end just so that it's not peaking at
the end and then that's really
all you're going to be doing for
mastering uh for the beginner course I
know it's that's very basic for right
now but
if if you're a complete beginner this is
your first time using FL Studio and you
can make a and you were able to make
this entire thing it's not clipping
above zero it's all the notes are in Key
you have a Melody that sounds okay like
you're doing absolutely fantastic and so
here's my advice to you so I'm gonna
basically just give you some producer
wisdom before you guys I send you guys
off to to either the next course if you
want to do the second part in the series
I'm not sure when that's going to be
coming out
um or if you guys want to just go on
your own at this point you have
everything that you need to uh here's
what I would say if you want to improve
extremely quickly what you want to do
first of all do not watch tons of
content maybe you just watch a couple
videos if you don't know where things
are that's it and then what I'd say is
make as much music as possible make a
song and then if it if it's not good
make another song don't keep working on
that other song if that's not good move
on make a new one make a new one ever
when I started producing I made a new
song every single day for like two
months and that made me increase in
skill faster than anything else that you
can do you will make way better music if
you fail over and over again and learn
from your mistakes gradually then if you
try to work on one project and make it
the best that you can I can promise you
that the second thing that I can push
you guys forward after learning
everything that I've taught you here
is uh start collaborating start uh start
collaborating with other artists uh find
people at your skill level so like go
into different discords
um and just find people in the Discord
and say hey you want to make some music
you want to collaborate how long have
you been producing oh you're new I'm new
why don't we make music together and
have some fun and you can try doing that
that's really that's a really great way
to to grow your skills is to produce
somebody maybe slightly above your skill
level or um at your skill level at least
um and that would be super super good
for you guys and then another thing that
you can do is just talk with producers
actually just uh you don't even have to
collaborate just talking with other
producers and letting and listening to
their music
um trying to give them feedback on their
music watching them produce uh it
Discord has a great feature I Discord is
honestly the way I learned how music
produced because I met many many
Fantastic producers that would literally
just stream and show how they would
produce and I just watch them and learn
from them and then they would work with
me and we'd all learn together and
uh so yeah that's a great way it's just
watching each other produce uh find
different uh platforms and forms and
discords where you can post your song
Get feedback on it and give feedback to
other people's songs uh that having that
critical ear where you can give feedback
to somebody and they can give feedback
to you is going to make you
exponentially increase in in uh in your
knowledge because what will happen is is
that people will say Hey you really need
to work on this and then you're like
okay cool and then you look up how to
learn that specific area of music
production and then you'll learn that
over time and that way you can focus on
different parts so
um I'm trying to think if there's
anything else I can give you guys before
you go because I remember there was a
lot of things as a beginner that annoyed
me and I'm trying to remember what they
were that way you guys don't have to go
through the same problems that I went
through
um when you're working on projects uh it
can be really difficult to remember all
the things you're like okay I have to
make chords I have to make uh I have to
mix I have to master I have to do all
this stuff automations all everything
you're remembering all at the same time
and holding all that like in your head
like makes it want to explode when
you're starting off and
trust me
most of the stuff it comes from habit uh
I don't remember all this in my head I I
there's no way I'd be able to do that
the reason I'm able to do this without
overthinking everything is because I
because of practice it's because of
habits we have a uh just um kind of like
Hands-On knowledge you get from working
uh and so that's also why I was telling
you guys that you should produce as much
as possible as fast as possible because
that will give you the most experience
and you won't have to overthink
everything uh you'll just be able to
kind of have the more like intuitive
instinctive uh producing feel for it and
you'll get kind of like that flow state
where you can just kind of produce and
you don't have to overthink everything
so that's that's one thing I see a lot
of uh younger producers doing is that
they overthink literally everything
instead of just making music and that
that can be really detrimental okay so a
few things a few extra things I just
remembered
um tried to remake songs that you really
like uh listen to a song that you like
and remake it and see how close you can
get it so I did that recently with uh I
forget which song it was we want to do a
Lipa songs I tried to remake it like
perfectly and I was able to get it to
sound almost exactly the same and that
was like really helpful for me it's just
trying to think about how they produce
and
so yeah do that if you can find people
breaking down songs how they made a like
a top chart song watch those breakdowns
uh Watch professional uh professional
artists uh master classes uh there's a
really good one by Hans Zimmer highly
recommend that
um just yeah listen and uh the content
that you want to consume is the kind of
content you want to be making but you
want to have a good ratio so you don't
want to be consuming all this content
like you don't want to go on YouTube and
just look up like a thousand tutorials
in a row and then get into FL Studio and
think that you're going to be insanely
good that's just not gonna happen okay
you don't want to go to reverse also uh
I would say that if you just only
produce all the time and you never
consume content I've actually seen some
producers have that problem as well and
what can happen is is that they never
kind of increase their skills they never
get to that next level and so there's
this little healthy balance where if you
can consume a decent amount of content
not too much if you can produce and put
out as much as you can with what you're
learning uh in an incremental stage and
you can spend time with people uh that
are better than you and with people
people that are at your skill level uh
just bouncing off and having a feedback
system there if you can have those three
parts of music production you will grow
as an artist and you will do fantastic
and I think that you guys are going to
do great and I hope that this course was
able to give you the foundations that
you need to start music producing and if
you have any questions uh you can just
email me or you can shoot me a message
in Discord
um I want to hear you guys tracks so for
free I will give you feedback on any of
your guys's tracks that you made from
this course so you can just tag the
producer course or whenever uh Tristan's
course and this send me an email and
then just send me your song and I'll
feedback it for free
um I also will do uh paid lessons so if
you want to know about those you can
email me
um and I can do a one hour or multiple
hour sessions with you and I can help
you out personally on a call and I can
see your project and try to help you out
with that so if that's something you're
interested in you can shoot me an email
I'm always available and I'm super
excited to hear what you guys are making
with this course
see ya
um I just realized actually I don't go
yet I forgot to tell you guys one of the
most important things before you're done
uh when you want to be finished with
your song you write a file export MP3
and what that's going to do you just
title your song whatever you want and
then you're gonna click save and then
export it through and then that's how
you export your song and then I forgot
to also say that with the free version
FL Studio the one drawback is that once
you export a song you cannot open it
back up okay so
once you export this song and if you
close this FL Studio file and open it
back up it won't let you open it without
the paid version FL Studio you might be
thinking oh man that's such a bummer
like man I want to open up and work on
the same song but I actually think that
it's fantastic for people who are
starting out because what happens is
that if a beginner just stays on the
same song it's actually worse for them
so in a weird way the free version FL
Studio is actually a benefit to you
because it forces you to always be
moving on to the next track and that's
the reason why I made so many tracks is
because I couldn't go back to the last
track once I was done with it once I
exported it that was it so uh yeah I
can't believe I forgot that so yeah once
you have the song then you have to
export it and then you can export the
MP3 file and save that and share it with
your friends and share it with people
so I guess I'll just play the song that
we finished here one time through and
then I will see you guys later
[Music]
okay
[Music]
um obviously as I said before this is
pretty funny to me because it just
sounds I don't know it's not something I
would normally make so uh yeah for the
beginner course I think it's it'll work
fine
um it's it's this is a learning tool
it's not something I would release but
uh hopefully that this guy this helped
you and um yeah I'm really excited to
move on to the more interesting and
difficult topics of music production so
I hope to do that soon and I'll see you
guys later
foreign
[Music]